mais là il aimait la vie mais son prénom
alors je viens de l'apprendre c'est jean
luc tu arrives faire un truc aujourd'hui
une troisième question oui bien sûr ce
que je veux ma maman m'a fait la
réflexion et je n'avais pas fait
attention
bah écoutez vous appelez tous les
chroniqueurs par leur prénom est vrai
par mon nom de famille oui mais pour
quelle raison cher ami parce que valérie
ça ne va pas non mais c'est vrai vous
savez vous comment alors comment vous
souhaiteriez me prénommé alors vous
franchement oui
régine prénom c'est quoi ton nom et un
prénom wali maxime
ah oui quand même oui c'est plus sous le
même délire coire écoute j'ai quand même
une famille qui est française une
famille qui essaie mais ils avaient
prévu un prénom au cas où ça tourne mal
tu me caroline ithurbide arts vous vous
avez un vous êtes pas un une tête vous
appelez caroline avant moi je déteste et
mon prénom est mon depuis quinze jours
d'accord et ben je m'appelais toujours
je m'inventais des prévenus quand
j'étais en vacances pour une italienne
les ex naples et victoria tout le monde
tous les vacances tous les mecs que je
rencontrais et où je les ai jamais
montré nez et encore moins aux mecs sur
toi aussi d'accord et c'est votre
deuxième prénom alors c'est à gagner ces
jeunes viennent et victorine 14 c'est un
prénom qui ne s'invente pas pour moi
c'est quoi aimer aimer ou a réagi mme
bachelot a aimé mais le bachelor ses
prédictions fabien on donne le nom de
l'oncle désaccord il faudra donc votre
oncle s'appelait mais aimer away et
d'orienter jacquet
maxime deuxième prénom c'est philippe
mais on dirait qu'elle a mis sur la
table mais on dirait qu'il va nous
sortie aux gens mohamed deuxième prénom
ses jambes ramed et tout le monde
l'appelle jean momo valérie vidal ou
quelle case canal+ a proposé à michel
drucker pour la rentrée prochaine vas-y
rigide
j ai donc ce que nous savons c'est andré
deuxième prix andré arrêt d'accord agile
ou en brave homme enfin vous êtes c'est
mal parti en fait j'ai assez bien
gilles c'est ben ouais nombreux succès à
une embuscade mais on part tôt mais sur
la france intra muros non dans les pays
de l'est
benjamin castaldi est longue quel est
votre deuxième prénom c'est c'est ses
anges au jeu mais comme mon père et de
mon grand père non c'est vraiment mon
vélo en fait moi je trouve que ça fait
beaucoup de moyens mon père il a
beaucoup péché simple anges
mon prénom nom michaud pecci injuste au
téléphone lui et je m'appelle orange les
mof qui fait l'eau avait toujours quoi
ai-je un troisième prénom yves yves as
well as assez appréciable